yeah and they brought you here huh well
her address she's just a couple miles up
the road
if you don't mind
I'm here with uh a very interesting
story so I just met Gary cook yes
correct that's right and you are on your
way literally to the city the city hall
of of Valrico but I'm interested in
moving down here but your GPS brought
you here and then you fell off of your
scooter yes and then you walked into my
office yes and we got to we fed you and
you got got you uh patched up here how
wonderful I really appreciate your
hospitality in the Enrico I'm gonna
enjoy living here with this kind of of
the camaraderie so they're not what I
told Gary I said nothing's by chance or
coincidence it was destined that he fell
off his scooter here by the dean Center
and we patched them up fed them and gave
them a gift wonderful I'll look forward
to that Koran yes thank you so much
appreciate it all right God bless you
wow that was something amazing so Mr
Gary cook goes and puts in his GPS
coordinates one destination Allah had a
different platform he gets them over
here to us at the future Dean Center
unfortunately he fell off his scooter at
82 years old and we got him inside got
him some water some food patched him up
a little bit and then we got him a gift
the verbatim word of God Almighty Allah
the Quran he got over 6 000 verses in
this book around a thousand of them deal
with scientific facts Miracles so you
could be assured that this is not
man-made but indeed from the creator of
the heavens and earth if you want to
know the purpose of life it's in this
book why you've been created where are
you going when you die it's in this book
facts not fiction
so you'd be a fool if you didn't pick it
up read it sincerely earnestly ask the
Creator to have his inner earth for
guidance so it's a message that's often
repeated worship the Creator not the
creation the love of Jesus is in this
book love of his blessed mother is in
this book
defining clearly to humanity how to be
successful in this life and the next
and to be morally upright on the
foundation of pure monotheism enough
said I'm gonna get you a free copy of
this Quran go to the deanshow.com to get
your free copy keep us in your Duos so
we can get officially open opening up
the Masjid and mega dollar Center at the
dean Santa we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalamualaikum
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters as
you can see we've acquired the property
and we're getting right to work and with
your duas and support we can go ahead
and get the Masjid and megadawa Center
up open and running insha Allah imagine
every person that prays here gets
educated and guided to Islam here you'll
get a part of all those blessings and
rewards insha Allah what are you waiting
for brothers and sisters you're going to
leave it all behind anyway so go ahead
and invest in your Hereafter that's
Everlasting click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
foreign